we're here in south san francisco at the
headquarters of dodocase cool thing
about this company is if it's a start-up
tied to the technology industry but it's
got this whole fresh take which is
bringing manufacturing back to San
Francisco the whole name is that they're
trying to keep book bindings for being
extinct practice in the digital age so
it's a pretty unique storage
tell me a little bit about how you guys
got started people continued moving away
from ink and paper to pixels to tablets
and e-readers that the artificial
finding is going to disappear we saw
that there is definitely going to be an
opportunity in the tablet space when the
ipad came out for a case company who
said why don't we allow that to drive
how the product is made it's like a
totally different vibe in here that a
typical software startup obviously yeah
absolutely it's weird being in San
Francisco and being in the mecca for a
tech startups and then doing something
that's so hands-on it's a really fancy
machine here it's too old screwdriver
this antenna hold hand press this clue
depress the 1940s 1950s era machine so
this is something bookbinders would have
been using yes that's cool
why does it matter that these are made
by hand you know we're not opposed to
using equipment where it where it works
and where it's necessary but we've
always found that the hand process is
more efficient so then you end up with
this really modern device and iPad
inside of here but like it feels
familiar like a book we all grew up
holding hardback books yeah so it's
something that makes an iPad a little
bit more personal a little bit more
comfortable but what happens as we have
all these people now coming in who grew
up with iPads and are they going to have
a desire for this time yeah the only
thing I could say on that front is my
three-year-old nephew is reading
hardback books so I think we've got a
few years where the tactile sensation of
holding a book is still going to be
relevant they're still parts of the
process that can't be replaced by a
machine that suppose if we had millions
of dollars through an automation
eventually we can get robots but it just
wouldn't be part of who we are so humans
still have opposable thumbs exact
higher-skilled the machines for sure